[Music]
in a world that's starting to get tired
of long running franchises comes another
installment of the long running
franchise that went from an exciting
canvas for directors to make a spy movie
to the Cru of mcari action stunt
spectacular step right up folks and
witness the ninth wonder of the world
tiny Tom Cruz a legend in the world of
cinematic acrobatics will Bol himself
off this very Cliff armed only with his
motorcycle and a steadfast belief in his
own abilities only $14 to see if he
survives the journey over the Alps onto
the speeding train and into the hearts
of patriotic Americans everywhere
Mission colon impossible dead reckoning
part one Ethan Hunt is back he's still
going rogue their habitual Rogue
Behavior will not be tolerated putting
us on an unsanctioned Mission which has
gone Rogue before it even started he
always goes Rogue still masking up and
still flexing the special skill section
of his resume it's
worthless without this key let M I'm
trying to get away from this B this time
he's up against the entity like Chi BT
if it could do more than just plagiarize
this dark Siri can impersonate anybody
turn left turn right Ethan you're
talking to the entity docks anyone throw
a sweet rager you could even say that
this party is that interested party and
predict every outcome but
one what if Barbie and Oppenheimer
released the next week and nuke the box
of us so hard no one cares
anymore is
thisty so it's like DJ software or
something I'll wait for part two bow
before Gabriel a Prestige version of the
im a m I'm a PC guys you no idea the
power I represent he's repping team anti
alongside this bag of quirks
masquerading as a henchman they're in a
hunt against hunt to locate a mysterious
key which is actually two keys so anyone
could have her half of the key that
combine to form one key two halves of
the cruciform key a very the key will be
mine important this key has got to
change the world key whatever the
completed key unlocks I will F help me
complete the key assuming we get the
complete key at the party tonight the
key to World Domination is of all things
a key in conclusion key the key is only
the beginning Elsa F returns as Ethan
Hunt's badass situationship it's my
first time in Menace then there's
newcomer Grace who shares Ethan's
affinity for close-up magic what the
and ability to play through a bad
concussion
it's okay slow all girl Grace Shake It
Off back in the
game Ethan's Handler kitridge returns
clearly still pissed that his suit
smells like aquarium
water it's my job to use you agent
Briggs is on his tail with one weird
trick that works 0% of the
time that oh oh oh and of course Benji
to return for a double dose of guy at
the computer yelling instructions Ethan
that is not me and guy at the computer
calmly giving instructions nothing to
worry about it's under control yes I
copy look I'm just trying to help you
with an algorithm on the loose everyone
will be plunged into a confusing world
of Lies whoever controls the entity
controls the truth where no one can know
what's real and what's misinformation
you're playing four-dimensional chess
with an algorithm and every claim has to
be second and third guessed what if
that's what the entity wants us to think
that's like the high stakes equivalent
of only getting your news from the app
formerly known as Twitter nothing anyone
says is true you better pull this one
off Ethan the AI is coming for us even
the
[Music]
actors so if you only see one stunt
first Blockbuster that Recons the
backstory with a driving Chas scene
along roam Spanish steps see this one
over fast X for sure here we go because
hey it might be one of the more
depressing installments but Tom is only
going to be able to do this one more
time okay what do you expect me to do
well just you know jump jump trust me
you're going to miss him when he's gone
like Shelly Mis
gabbage
starring Ethan stunt how we not done
that one already at well that ends well
Sha of the FED mama Med no Morales
Gerard slle Eugene kitridge Chief Wiggum
and black hat what it's a hacking term
jeez mission improbable stunt on these
fo you know it's so fun that they
brought back kitridge now when is Amelio
EST is going to return in the franchise
all right his
face hey screen junkies we got the
chance to waste 10 minutes of invincible
Creator Robert kirkman's time so he made
him react to our honest trailer for
invincible I enjoy Honest Trailers
myself and I watch them all the time and
then to see that thing you enjoy turned
on you is pretty heartbreaking and I
don't enjoy it click the box in the
right to watch him turn the tables on
our you ever wonder what a booger smells
like I recently hiked the Appalachian
Trail it was just the width but it's a
star
oh baby you you got what I need but you
say he's just a friend and you say he's
just a friend sounds like Tracy Morgan
what these things